my uh learned
adversary has dealt with what I suppose
one would call the performative aspect
of the matter in
hand he's not here to hear me um I shall
uh try and deal with the
informative um he had of course the
advantage of four strings I was going to
bring my Viola which is which was
Beethoven's instrument
but
[Music]
um back and I heard
yeah and but um bet never wrote anything
for viod and if I had the time which I
don't I would tell you why because it'll
take 50 minutes of psycho analysis to
explain why um in very modern terms
Beethoven turned against the vi was
quite fond of the cello and he was quite
fond of the cello Beethoven and indeed
of chellis one of his best friends was a
man called count Mescal who was a senior
civil servant who stole very high
quality government paper for Beethoven
to write on and he also tried to get
Beethoven to accompany him on brothel
crawls
unsuccessfully but these cellists know
how to live um I must just quickly say
that I've given a recital on Beethoven's
own cello in the Beethoven house in Bon
with the great musician s Andi
and um it was an honor but sorry go
allegedly his own
cello unless it was stolen from her
majesty stationary office
um at the risk of lowering the
tone um I just like to deal with a
philosophical matter for a second there
is a debate between um valter Benyamin
and gam schan as to which is more
important is it more important to be
original for an artist to be original or
trans transmissible is it more important
to create something that is
unprecedented or something that can be
passed on and here we have the Schism
the great division between bak and Boven
Bak is a Monumental figure in music um
he is the repository of all the music
that has come before him translated into
a way that can be handed forward there
is hardly any composer who is more
quoted by his successes from Heiden to
sh stovich than your an Sebastian B
there is hardly any composer who is
quoted less by his successors than lud F
Beethoven Beethoven's originality was
daunting everything he did was new he
didn't Bak like all composers of his
period quoted from himself quoted from
others lifted whole concertos of evaldi
and put them out under his own name with
a different solo instrument
um it was come on it was the 18th
century it's what you did Beethoven is
in the 19th century Beethoven is looking
consistently forward in everything that
he does everything from the very first
moment that he sets forth sets foot in
Vienna is totally and completely new he
comes to Vienna a few months after
Mozart's died and everybody says oh he's
a talented boy he could be the next
Mozart bet says no do not mistake me for
anyone else I'd like to ask Mishka just
to play us a little bit of the Opus 10
number two it's the fifth Piano Sonata
it's written for a Mrs Brown you heard
it
um yeah he was one of Mrs Brown's Boys
um it's written for a Mrs Brown who was
the wife of the head of intelligence at
the Russian Embassy so she's also Mrs
Putin
um and it is one of the ways in which
Beethoven says to the world I am
Beethoven there is no other m
[Music]
for